[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ses idées qui gouvernent
le monde nous allons vous parler de la
filiation fils de filles de nous le
sommes tous alors nous vivons une
période où le narcissisme de masse
imprime l'air du temps bien souvent on
est catalogué parce qu'on consomme je
suis ce que je consomme entre mendient
faisons table rase du passé et jouissons
sans limite du présent ce qui constitue
un leurre on se rend compte avec cette
période de kovy d'où nous avons été
isolés et ce conflit en ukraine où nous
sommes rattrapés par la peur aussi nous
allons être au cours de cette émission à
rebrousse poil du sens du vent et d'une
société sans père ni repère pour vous
parler de transmission de filiation
d'identité d'intimité d'où nous venons
et où nous allons bref nous allons
parler de nos géniteurs de nos maîtres
des traditions de nos rêves de ce que
nous sommes fils de fil 2 et nous allons
chercher à transmettre et vous allez le
faire par les livres par voie mémoire
par votre engagement au cours de votre
exercice professionnel mais aussi dans
vos engagements politiques
vous allez partager avec nous cette
parole pleine merci d'être avec nous et
je vous présente mes invités marc
lambron vous êtes écrivain et vous êtes
de l'académie française eliette
abécassis use est normalienne et
écrivaine rachel kahn vous êtes juriste
et femmes politiques
maurice mimoun vous êtes chirurgien des
hôpitaux et vous êtes également écrivain
[Musique]
alors nous allons commencer évidemment
par les maux dont vous venez de voir la
citation de gérard depardieu qu'est ce
que vous avez gagné avec les mots vos
premiers mots qui a fait de chacune et
chacun d'entre vous des êtres parlants
des êtres sociaux marc lambron les mots
d'abord c'est le titre comme vous le
savez de l'autobiographie de sartre de
son récit d'enfance alors moi je crois
que dans la filiation il ya des
filiations qui sont je dirais imposé ou
en tout cas naturel n'est pas culturel
c'est-à-dire la naissance la génétique
le lieu de naissance éventuellement la
confession et puis il ya les filiations
choisi et qui sont celles qui
m'intéresse le plus c'est à dire que
l'être humain où l'animal parlant et
doté d'une intelligence et dotés de
mémoire et on peut tout à fait aller
chercher dans l'arbre généalogique qui
n'est pas celui de la filiation
génétique mais de l'affiliation
culturelle où se niche et malraux disait
une bibliothèque c'est l'héritage de la
noblesse du monde eh bien nous avons
l'opportunité d'aller nous promener à
travers ce qui a été héritée
et de choisir nos prédécesseurs en
quelque sorte il ya même cette idée en
littérature on pourra y revenir que nous
influençons nos prédécesseurs
je vous donne un exemple
il y avait dans les années 30 par
exemple en france une mode une vague des
grands récits cycle jules romain roger
martin du gard montherlant dont vous
aviez les hommes de bonne volonté les
thibault les jeunes filles et il est
intéressant de voir que ses auteurs
aujourd'hui sont assez oxydé passe pour
périmés sont très peu lu alors même que
la petite musique d'autres auteurs pour
un exemple c'est emmanuel berl par
exemple vous pouvez nous dire aux
également quelles ont été vos premiers
mots si je puis dire quels ont été les
premiers mots à la ça c'est très
difficile parce que le l'oralité
première je n'en sais rien peut-être été
maman peut-être ça a été je ne saurais
pas le dire quelque chose d'ailleurs
intéressante que n'oublie c'est que nous
sommes tous analphabètes au moins
pendant les trois ou les quatre
premières années de notre vie ce dont je
me souviens très vaguement c'est qu'il
ya eu un temps où je ne faisais pas le
rapport entre le signe et le sens
j'avais trois quatre ans je voyais un
panneau indicateur ou avec mais je ne
savais pas on va on va avancer en âge
mais alors il y est avec assiste les
premiers mots ce dont vous souvenez qui
font de vous ce que vous êtes devenu une
écrivaine voilà c'est ça il ya les mots
de l'écrit et les mots orolia la peña
parole qui se transmet oralement et puis
peut-être à partir ou pas d'un texte
écrit pour moi c'était beaucoup la
parole de mon père mais hausse mais
aussi de ma mère qui est psychologue de
l'enfant donc qui s'est intéressé
beaucoup à la parole elle faisait
pendant mon enfance était justement sur
le langage non verbal chez les enfants
donc les premiers mots des enfants ont
été très observé par les deux le
philosophe et la psychologue et je pense
que cette parole orale
elle est très importante surtout dans
notre société où elle revient et
peut-être qu'il faut revenir vers cette
transmission cette forme de transmission
là une fois que les cris aura
définitivement disparu là vous êtes
pessimiste on va essayer d'être plus
optimistes avec rachel kahn alors ses
premiers mots lyall à moi de manière un
peu
surprenant peut-être en tout cas parce
qu'on est ici sur cette chaîne là mon
premier mot c'était mon bar et ça
voulait dire raymond barre dire que je
suis né en 76 et mon père donc
le français n'ont personne pour mon père
c'est la cinquième langue en fait le
français et il est passionné encore
aujourd'hui de politique et donc il me
parlait de raymond barre alors que je
venais de naître et une premiers mots
c'est mon bas avant gâteau maman papa
c'est par hasard vous êtes tombé vers
les dires dans la politique
maurice mimoun alors là on le rappelle
absolument pas de mes premiers mots mais
ça devait être maman est ce que les
jeux je pense que les mots sont dans les
yeux des parents voilà et donc non ce
qui est intéressant chez moi c'est que
on ne lisait pas beaucoup chez moi
puisque mon père était un inventeur même
touché pas un livre il m'a appris la vie
d'une autre manière et ma mère ge
s'astreignait à lire l aisselle me
montrer que c'était important de lire et
les mots pas été très jeune je n'ai pas
compris tout de suite que les mots est
important pour moi mais alors vous dites
les uns et les autres à parler des mots
en parlant de les mots du père des mots
de la mer selon goethe on tient de
l'assurance et du sérieux de la vie ça
vient du père selon le poète allemand et
la joie de vivre et l'imagination
viendrait de la mer est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec ça eliette abécassis
plus vous avez une mère qui égaie
psychologue un père qui est philosophe
oui est ce que cette distinction que tn
si on peut dire vous parle entre le
sérieux et la joie je sais pas si on
peut faire en tout cas c'est vrai que la
période la parole du père et
structurante et elle donne la direction
et disons que la mère je pense en tout
cas au début c'est peut-être plus du
côté d'un effectif c'est peut-être ce
qu'il a voulu dire même si aujourd'hui
tout ça est remis en question mais c'est
vrai que pour moi cette parole a été
très c'était une parole de sens mais
aussi de deux sens et d'ouverture du
chance en fait c'est à dire que c'est
une parole d'interprétation mon père a
fait sa thèse sur l'interprétation et
c'est vraiment le maître de
l'interprétation des paroles écrites
d'une façon où il va les rangs actuelle
les rendre pertinente et sans cesse
différentes c'est ça qui est formidable
c'est l'infini de l'interprétation d'une
parole qui renvoie et notre parole est
allé skier alors une dissonance entre
les géniteurs de marc lambron entre
monsieur lambron une madame lambron moi
je suis d'accord à cette classification
je suis un très beau et cobayes je viens
pourquoi parce que j'ai été au début des
années 60 et c'était souvent le cas un
enfant divisé où un enfant confié c'est
à dire que jusqu'à l'âge de l'école
maternelle je passe le plus clair de ma
semaine chez mes grands-parents donc qui
était très proche de mes parents
d'ailleurs donc il y avait cinq femmes
chance ma mère mais qui était un peu
latéralisé il y avait ma grand mère mon
arrière grand mère et mes deux jeunes
tentent donc je vis dans une sorte de
bain amniotique prolongée et je vis dans
l'enchantement dans la grâce du verbe
des femmes des voix même même un
enterrement terme de sonorités donc il
ya cette idée d'un d'une origine qui
serait féminine pour moi est ok le cas
de rome après tout les oui mais je veux
pas dire que c'est une sorte de harem
familialement fin j'avais j'avais ces
quatre femmes ce qui fait que j'ai une
sorte de paradis
inaugural qu'ensuite j'ai pu avoir le
sentiment notamment quand je vais à
l'école maternelle de découvrir la
violence des autres petits garçons
donc je suis un peu androphone
finalement et en même temps j'ai ce
paradis initial qui ne s'adonne manière
me structure encore c'est à dire que je
suis en plein dans la vie à dire oui
plutôt que non
et vous tenez le oui le nom du père et
de la mère ou sa soeur elle retient le
oui des femmes et le non je ne peux pas
le dire je n'aime pas le j'aime pas le
nihilisme le nom ça vient de vous je
préfère acquiescé mais évidemment après
la vie avec ses importants et ses
fâcheuses fait que vous êtes parfois
évidemment ami a amené à dire non alors
le nom et le nom est postérieure il est
acquis et le oui est premier maurice
mimoun en général pour of frog considère
que la puissance d'agir
chez un homme c'est la mère qui le donne
mais là on voit que got ne dit pas
exactement la même chose pour vous c'est
qui la puissance d'agir vous tenez ça de
l'amour maternel
moi je tiens ça de d2 jeu pour ce qui
est intéressant je crois que c'est la
phrase qui vous écoutent ce que vous
pouvez vous lâcher non mais c'est
surtout je pense qu'à l'heure actuelle
c'est plus du tout vrai on peut pas
distinguer famille de cette manière je
crois que ce qui est intéressant dans l'
affaire c'est que pour élever un enfant
je crois qu'il faut être deux personnes
non c'est ça qu'on peut dire dans une
société moderne s'il ya deux personnes
qui roulent à bascule on sait pas où
aller ou là où la féminité et la
masculinité on sait pas où aller ce pack
deux hommes ça peut être deux femmes ça
peut être une femme un homme et puis moi
j'ai été élevé aussi dans un milieu avec
un impair charismatique deux soeurs et
une mère je suis je n'ai jamais tenu un
pistolet marche d'ailleurs très étonnée
qu'on puisse donner des pistes mais aux
enfants mais et je jouais la poupe est
bon et sa maman et samaa et ça m'a
beaucoup à la marraine ça m'a beaucoup
savent a beaucoup amusé j'étais dans ce
milieu où il y avait mon père qui a
regardé tout ça et c'est normal pour
tout le monde donc ça c'est ma manière
de pas de m'en être sorti parce que j'ai
vécu une enfance très heureuse mais
c'est une manière de dire que
effectivement un moment donné ont choisi
certaines certaines paternité maternité
ou charme certain certaines choses mais
qui en fait je ne pense pas que c'est
très difficile de d'élever un enfant à
une voix je pense qu'il faut qu'il y ait
de l'enfant doit choisir une deuxième
voie quelques parle des grands parents à
mettre quelque chose il faut être de
perdre sa rentrée on va rentrer
là-dedans belle rachel kahn vous entre
le père et la mère il y à une altérité
est ce que votre avis elle vous a
reformé différemment sur le plan des
sentiments de votre action de ce que
vous êtes et à dire la phrase de goethe
est en est intéressante en tout cas dans
mon cas par rapport aux clichés aux
assignations
sur l'ajoie que peut être une mère
ashkénazes
vous pouvez dire ce que ça veut dire
non mais c'est à dire que bon dans le
cliché de la sq est naze c'est pas la
joie qui les définissent le mieux ma
mère est née en 1940 a été cachée en
poitou charentes donc elle a retrouvé
par chance mes grands parents que j'ai
pu connaître
après la guerre ils sont arrivés à
l'hôtel lutetia et de l'autre côté la
rigueur le sérieux de l'homme africain
ça rentre pas non plus dans le cliché
donc là on est à contre pied de tout en
revanche ce que je peux dire de ma mère
était libraire donc les mots m'ont
entouré et c'est vrai que mes parents se
sont rencontrés dans la librairie de ma
mère
en revanche comme le métier de libraire
est un métier une militants je voyais
très peu ma mère qui était dans les
cartons et les colliers les commandes
pour nous les auteurs
ma langue maternelle c'est ma langue
maternelle c'est dire que c'est mon père
qui par amour du français m'a transmis
cette langue là donc effectivement je
remets en question peut-être cette
citation de gouy en tout cas cessé je
vous rejoins sur la conjugaison des deux
stars que la langue d'un enfant c'est
une histoire de conjugaison mais est ce
que vous diriez que pour réussir il faut
avoir une réserve d'amour pour réussir
c'est la langue de l'amour en tout cas
moi c'est celle qui met en tout cas les
mots que mon père m'a transmis
des français c'est dangereux de penser
ça parce que ce justement de mon livre
je de moi qui dis dans mon livre qui a
peur parfait je me jette tout de suite
moi qui suis médecin je me suis dit
qu'est ce que vont dire les gens quand
on perd détestable un père absent à
faire voilà non il faut que je pense que
la réserve d'amour on en fait ce que
l'on veut après on a son choix ça peut
être très très négatif une réserve de
trop d'amour c'est pas d'amour il ya une
bombe ou un mot à la mode la résilience
mais il ya des choses qui sont possibles
aussi mais l'amour l'amour peut-être moi
mon père a été un père extrêmement
rigoureux et exigeant et j'ai compris
très tard que c'était de l'amour bien
longtemps qu'il faut pas que l'arbre
historiciser ça c'est à dire qu'est ce
que c'était qu'un père des années 50 ou
soit exactement et là on va rentrer une
mutation anthropologique employés un
grand mot c'était pas la même chose
après chacun chaque enfant mon avis est
assez plastique est assez souple ça par
exemple j'avais une même ma mère était
institutrice et ça veut dire qu'elle
passait le plus clair de sa journée avec
25 autres enfants qui n'était pas moi et
pour autant vous étiez jaloux non eh ben
pour autant et veut pas du tout et comme
j'en avais peut-être marre le soir
d'avoir accueilli à corriger et c'est
qu'ils étaient assez bons élèves
finalement j'avais une mère institutrice
sans tutelle
scolaire après les après les heures de
classe elle me laissait elle me laissait
courir elle me laissait filer voilà donc
il ya des configurations différentes
après chacun trouve sa place eliette
abécassis sur la question en cette
question là je vais vous laisser
répondre mais je voudrais aussi que vous
apportiez votre point de vue sur le fait
que
chez l'adulte que vous êtes aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous guider vous garder une
part de l'enfance sous les espèces du
désir c'est à dire que quand vous
désirez quelque chose c'est l'enfant
vous qui le désirent tout en étant
adulte ah oui je crois que c'est très
important de garder cette part là
d'enfance de curiosité d'avoir envie de
tout c'est ça qui est admirable chez les
enfants et il faut il faut la garder à
tout prix et puis quand ma part
d'enfance je pense que c'est dans
l'écriture finalement de se lancer dans
un roman qui est qui va distraire qui va
emmener
le lecteur par la main pour l'ouvrir à
des univers même si à la transmission
dans ses romans la est toujours un côté
ludique et l'enfant joue et ses salles
en fort non deux mots en deux mots parce
qu'on a beaucoup de questions est ce que
vous diriez vous avez tous vous écrivez
tous des livres est ce que vous diriez
que vous pouvez écrire des livres parce
que l'enfant revient vous
c'est ambigu parce qu'alors que c'est
l'enfant qui tient la plume à la
définition freudienne de l'enfance et le
pervers polymorphe et frey dit le chemin
de la réalité est balisé d'objets perdus
ces taxes pour accéder à l'âge adulte il
faut quand même deux semblent de
renoncement donc je pense que et écrire
ou grandir c'est précisément savoir ce à
quoi on renonce est ce qu'on conserve
baudelaire dit que la poésie ou
l'écriture c'est précisément une part
d'enfance qui est conservé et qui est
propulsé projeté dans mon écriture
mais évidemment dans les strates
archaïque l'enfant il est toujours là et
il peut être douloureux où il peut être
contraire comblé et avec cette réserve
d'amour de vous par loris mimoun c'est
l'enfant qui a tenu la plume du livre
lorsque vous rats alors moi je suis au
contraire tous les invités moi j'avais
des parents qui lisait pas donc c'est
eux qui m'ont appris à quatre avec a6
a10 la curiosité moi j'avais un père
curieux il m'a appris la nature il
appris à observer c'est à partir d'une
éducation absolument à côté je croyais
qu'il n'était pas cultivé mais était
énormément cultiver d'autres choses et
c'est par cette observation que je sais
soigner je sers voir la personne
comprendre la personne et non pas
uniquement la maladie comprend la nature
et pouvoir écrire et écrire moi ça a été
à contre emploi c'est à dire autant
j'étais manuel parce que mon père était
un inventeur et j'allais en atelier à la
maison autant les mots je me suis
intéressé très tard et j'ai compris très
tard clémot est important et j'ai voulu
être cultivée j'ai voulu pouvoir écrire
parce que justement mes parents ne
n'écrivait pas c'est un contre-emploi je
m'émerveille aujourd'hui d'y être arrivé
mais pas du tout d'être chargé on a bien
compris rachel kahn voulait dire un mot
là-dessus sur la part damphousse oui la
parole
jeux oui et non dans mon premier roman
oui
dans dans race et sur les mots
pas du tout vous êtes devenu grand oui
[Musique]
vous n'êtes voir incitation de régis
debray il faut toujours un maître pour
apprendre à se passer de m alors est-ce
qu'il faut toujours un m est-ce qu'il
faut toujours se donner à m pour sortir
du pur raisonnement et apprendre tout
simplement rachel kahn en plus m c'est
lourd de sens l'âme vous allez vous
prendre des rafales de un buzz de dubeau
qui semé tout ça moi je pense que les
maîtres wisson sont nécessaires pour un
pour l'affranchissement moi qui suis
enfin je viens aux maux du sport que
j'étais une sportive de haut niveau en
équipe de france et le chronomètre était
mon maître et c'est la bataille contre
le chronomètre qui m'a donné cette
exigence pour le dépassement du corps
notamment et après je crois que dans
toutes les disciplines danse classique
comme l'écriture comme la politique
il faut savoir le m et 1 et 1 et 1 est
quelqu'un de généreux l'air de rien oui
eliette abécassis il faut toujours à m
pour sortir du pur raisonnement de la
raison pure et pour eux oui oui bien sûr
et pour sortir de ces préjugés et il
faut encore plus d'émettre aujourd'hui
parce que quand je compare à la façon
dont nos parents ont été élevés
justement d'une façon traditionnelle
avec des vrais maîtres au sens
au sens propre du terme aujourd'hui les
maîtres c'est quoi c'est bath et les
réseaux sociaux et donc c'est une
avalanche de choses qui ne sont pas
forcément fausse mais pas toujours vrai
non plus donc on ne sait plus en fait
distinguer entre le vrai le front et le
faut et on a d'autant plus besoin de non
seulement de mettre mes deux guides
spirituels d'intellectuels de
philosophes c'est devient vitale alors
maintenant bron m c'est pas forcément un
père mais est ce que quand on est
écrivain ce qui est votre profession si
je puis dire est ce que quand on est est
ce qu'on ne peut pas re quand on n'a pas
un père comme maître on peut trouver des
bêtes de substitution et ça permet de
jongler avec ça est assez amusant sexy
citation de régis debray qui a
précisément raconter comment ils
n'avaient pas cessé de faire le deuil de
ses maîtres il ya un livre qui s'appelle
loués soient nos seigneurs qui est un
adieu althusser à fidel castro à
mitterrand donc un m c'est aussi ce par
quoi on peut se fourvoyer et avoir le
sentiment ensuite précisément de ceux de
quitter le m alors moi je dirais que le
maître est bon quand précisément on à
désespérer de la maîtrise c'est à dire
qu'on s'est émancipée des tuteurs et
qu'on choisit à ce moment là mais par
élections et pas sur un mode infantile
ceux auxquels on se réfère on se
rapporte ce qu'on admire finalement donc
pour moi le maître se serait
l'admiration tardive une fois qu'on a
fait le deuil d'un certain nombre de
signifier ans m comme dit comme dit
l'attaquant mais risque de vous en
pensez mais le maître et perd c'est
complètement différent le père on ne le
choisit pas et on l'a malgré soi ou avec
soin le m c'est tombé en admiration en
amour ma mais j'ai eu des maîtres je
suis tombé amoureux de maître le
professeur bo qui m'a appris voilà il
est encore vivant jeu j'y pense tous les
jours et je vois dans les gestes que je
fais qu'il m'a appris
kundera cela première lecture qui m'a
qui m'a absolument
estomaqué c'est bon selon m en
littérature donc on les choisit et on
peut en être déçu un père il faut faire
avec réglage oui alors alger leucan
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
citation de diderot les mauvais père ce
sont ceux qui ont oublié les fautes de
leur jeunesse est ce que dans cette
période on critique beaucoup les pères
est-ce que ça on pourrait les
réhabiliter de cette manière là
des pères qui se souviennent de leur
faute pour transmettre en fait une vie à
leurs enfants avec leurs d'avoir appris
de leurs erreurs en gros c'est ça
oui certainement de toute façon
effectivement mais c'est vrai qu'on
crache beaucoup sur les pères
aujourd'hui
je pense notamment à cette situation je
suis sur les deux continents européen et
africain
et je pense puisque on est vraiment
autour des livres
à senghor sur qui on crache aujourd'hui
alors même que on estime aujourd'hui
avec ce regard très contemporain qu'il a
fait certaines fautes et notamment par
rapport à l'occident alors qu'il voulait
simplement tisser réparé avec ses mots
il est temps alors je sais combien dans
une lutte contre le patriarcat mais
aussi il est temps de reconnaître ce que
les pères ont pu nous apporter pour
grandir et pour plus d'égalité et
d'émancipation vous avez maurice mimoun
a évoqué kundera oui kundera
dans un livre c'était une conférence
hellemmes en occident kidnappés il a
montré que les petites nations qui se
trouvait en europe centrale avais tu es
qui dans leur culture avait été kidnappé
d'un côté par la russie ce d'ailleurs
d'actualité ou de l'autre côté par
l'allemagne est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment que l'afrique est aussi dans
ce cas là c'est dénoncer différents et
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que les
mouvements aujourd'hui qui arrive
cinquante ans plus tard les mouvements
des coloniaux sont pas dans cette
situation là ce ne sont pas les mêmes
histoires et c'est vraiment la fru ndi
qui vous parle ce qui a pu se passer en
afrique et aujourd'hui on a beaucoup pas
réparé notamment avec les mots en
français de la francophonie qui tracent
autre chose dans l'histoire de nos
humanités je pense que sur les
différents continents on a tous un un
fils à pouvoir recoudre de continent à
continent mais ce n'est pas tout à fait
la même histoire nous nous ont parlé
d'oralité tout à l'heure l'histoire
africaine a beaucoup d'oralité a livré
aujourd'hui au monde certes mais on sait
pas la même situation que que cette
situation en ukraine
oui maurice mimoun vous en prie
les petites nations les peuples des
petites nations avait peur pour leur
existence qui n'est pas le cas des
grandes nations ses dires ont pensé que
c'était tout les petits pays pouvait
disparaître ce qui est vrai mais
maintenant on peut suivre et même pour
les grands pays comme l'ukraine donc on
va se coucher c'est c'est terrifiant si
on passe des petites nations
aux individus eliette abécassis vous
avez le sentiment que on a du mal
avec les évolutions
multiculturelle mondialisé a gardé un
berceau culturel berceau de tradition et
c'est parce qu'il y a une espèce
d'uniformisation mondialisé qui empêche
qui nous empêchent de garder ce ce
capital que les valets et donc il ya une
perte d'identité je pense une perte de
repères on sait plus très bien comment
se situer ni mon nez et les enfants les
adolescents deviennent les enfants des
réseaux sociaux et finalement leur père
c'est leur maître ce sont les réseaux et
leur identité leur vient aussi de là l
or donc ils savent plus où ils en sont
et je pense que c'est très important
effectivement de s'inscrire dans une
culture une tradition ses repères qui
nous permette d'avoir quand même une
direction même même si on les remet en
question au moins c'est un socle et on
ne peut créer que par rapport à une
tradition et par rapport à cette remise
en cause de nous l'on vient mais en
laissant à les
et cette génération là qui a été élevé
avec les réseaux avec la technologie qui
nous apporte beaucoup de bienfaits je
remet pas cela en cause et je ne veux
pas revenir à un temps d'avant pas du
tout la technologie n'est ni bonne ni
mauvaise elle est ce qu'on en fait et on
a tendance à en faire une sorte de
substitut de mettre deux paires de
parents de frères deux soeurs de tout en
fait on lui délègue tous et c'est ça qui
est très dangereux aussi tu es marc
lambron par rapport à leurs additions
modernité qu'est-ce qu'on garde pour
garder une authenticité en quelque sort
m'intéresse beaucoup parce que pour moi
la tradition l'antériorité c'est comme
une boîte à outils où on peut aller
saisir telle ou alors la lecture de
senghor aujourd'hui elle a tendance à
être hystériser ou essentialiser sur le
thème de la négritude ça ça va avec la
culture ou moi je veux dire ce que m'a
appris senghor
quand j'étais
homme sait que 1 on pouvait être agrégé
de grammaire
et ancien élève du lycée louis le grand
et 2 on pouvait être un poète qui dans
une prose ou dans une verse un français
incorporait ce qu'on pourrait appeler
l'africanité c'est à dire le griot le
tambour parlant le et que ça n'était pas
contraire ou opposé à mon petit niveau
qu'est ce que m'a dit senghor que je
pouvais lire diderot et mais mick jagger
en somme que l'on pouvait se bricoler se
fabrique et finalement une une culture
et à l'agrément qui s d es ce que c'est
pas un peu exceptionnel va par exemple
dans vos livres
effectivement il ya à la fois la grande
culture classique et de la musique très
moderne mais pour le commun des mortels
sait pas si évident alors sont là où
vous pouvez dire je suis resté un
pervers polymorphe comment comme le
disait tout à l'heure c'est à dire que
la part d'enfance et très précisément
dans une certaine aptitude à se promener
dans divers registres pour faire écouter
il ya quand même beaucoup de gens qui
vont dans les musées
on un livre de poche avec eux vont au
cinéma enfin on vit quand même
maintenant dans un principe et pour pas
très cher d'ailleurs dans une sorte
d'omnium culturelles ou de musée
imaginaire la notion de musée imaginaire
qui essaient de malraux on peut tous
faire élection d'un musée imaginaire et
décliné nos préférences qui précisément
sont comme un arbre généalogique choisit
alors maurice mimoun ans vous avez vécu
une enfance idéal à vous lire avec votre
père au tout tout se serait bien passé
mais la question qui se pose c'est qu'on
dit que quand il n'y a pas d'autorité
quand il n'ya pas de hiérarchie entre
les enfants et les parents entre les
maîtres et les élèves en général quand
y'a pas d'autorité il n'y a pas de
transmission possible est-ce que se
vouent pense vous êtes d'accord avec ça
en tout cas chez moi il y avait une
autorité
mon père avait l'autorité naturelle
jamais vu m'engueuler mais je veux dire
on le respectait et il était un peu plus
loin à ma mère et vous savez c'est pour
ça qu'il faut toujours être de il ya une
personne qui est plus près de l'enfant
qui fait plus le quotidien est une
personne qui peut être un peu plus loin
qui peut qui peut donner des choses plus
générale ou réciproquement ou un peu des
deux bon ben moi ça s'est passé comme ça
ma mère était très proche et mon père
était un petit peu éloigné donc je les
structures et comme j'ai voulu si un
père c'est le sait le regard de l'enfant
et l'homme et l'homme que je vois c'est
pas ce qu'il est vraiment se
se sont à faire cet album c'est pas le
sait pas le mien mais assez ce que j'en
ai fait et avec la personne mais avec
avec un père et avec d'autres maîtres
c'est pareil on en fait c'est ce que
l'on met le père vous en faisiez une
pâte à modeler où il gardait son
autorité
c'est à dire que oui il gardait son
autorité parce que je sais pas eu ce
n'est pas eu à l'ua
à lui reprocher quelque chose de majeur
et c'était en fait il était saoul il
avait une autorité mais il était très
féminin en fait très sensible je m'en
suis aperçu qu un jour je suis un peu
tombé dans les pommes et j'ai vu les
larmes aux yeux ce qui m'a étonné
énormément tout d'un coup de ce père qui
était charismatique et vous rachel kahn
nous pensé par si on transpose ça la
politique que l'absence d'autorité
l'absence de hiérarchie ce
sacré le foutoir ah oui ça crie mal
absolu les problématiques des la perte
de repères pour bien les nommer de
manière lacanienne ces salles autorité
allait absolument nécessaire et quel
émerveillement de voir son père ému et
de découvrir que son père à ses émotions
et de découvrir qu'en fait cette rigueur
et cette exigence c'était que des
preuves d'amour à la fin de se rendre
compte que cet héritage c'était que des
preuves d'amour moi mes parents m'ont
élevée dans une exigence
d'égalité de liberté de fraternité c'est
une vraie exigence par bandelette une
vraie république eh ben c'est à dire
qu'en fait moi je n'aurais pas pu naître
ailleurs qu'en france vous voyez bien
entre la shoah la décolonisation
l'immigration et cet amour is ils ont
ils ont en fait succombé alors liberté
avoir l'exigence de cette liberté de ces
mets tous les deux pour faire des
enfants et donc en somme
moi mes racines mon adn il est forcément
républicains puisque j'aurais pas pu
naître ailleurs merci
[Musique]
nous allons passer maintenant avec un
trait d'union naturel de l'affiliation à
la transmission est ce que vous diriez
eliette abécassis qu'on ne transmet que
ce qu'on a reçu
alors non on l'espère bien que non
j'ai cru voir une citation de votre père
à ce sujet windows of oui en fait c'est
la question essentielle de notre époque
que transmettre comment transmettre
c'est une question cruciale aujourd'hui
parce que on ne sait plus et on ne sait
plus parce que effectivement y'a plus
tous ses repères religieux mais et même
culturelle que l'on avait avant donc que
transmettent et puis comment le
transmettre dans quelle sorte de
relation parent-enfant l'école est aussi
complètement
bouleversé avec les algorithmes et et
voilà un nouveau type de transmission
qu'on nous propose et et bien sûr on ne
transmet pas que ce qu'on a reçu parce
que on doit transmettre dans la
créativité et dans
la nouveauté de l'interprétation et
l'enrichissement permanent mais on
transmet forcément à partir de ce que
l'on a reçu
d'où le fait que transmettre soit
essentielle parce que sinon on n'a rien
reçu on ne transmettre à rien c'est
votre avis maintenant bron je crois que
c'est une question qui se pose au moins
sur trois générations c'est-à-dire
celles de nos enfants la nôtre celle de
nos parents à moi par exemple pour le
dire vite je crois que je suis un enfant
de la gratitude paradoxal c'est à dire
que j'avais un père qui était un homme
très droit assez sévère il a eu une
première éducation dans des écoles
militaires et ce qui me constitue c'est
à la fois cet exemple de rectitude et en
même temps l'écart par rapport à ça
parce que moi je suis adolescent au
début des années soixante dix donc je
suis aussi fils de mes deux maisons que
si j'ose dire ou deux c'est à dire 68 et
finalement je crois que je me constitue
dans une sorte de dialectique entre la
loi et ceux qui contestent la loi mais
ça ouvre évidemment des perspectives et
quand on est au moment de transmettre
soi même je pense qu'on à l'héritage on
a le lait en tout cas moi je n'ai eu des
deux c'est à dire une fois quelque chose
qui tient une sorte de rigueur verticale
et un temps quelque chose qui serait le
plaisir d'un hédonisme conquis dans ces
époques libertaire des années 70 et ça
je pense que je lui ai transmis d'une
manière ou d'une autre à mes enfants
sont d'ailleurs être forcément le pas
forcément conscients évidemment de ceux
qu'on transmet mais on voit après comme
en miroir peut-être plus tard le ce que
le dépôt enfin en tout cas ce que ça
allait sécher les jo maurice mimoun pont
pardonnez moi je vais donner la parole à
maurice mimoun parce que vous avez la
réputation d'avoir des doigts d'or comme
chirurgien vous tenez ça doit de pair
oui moi je vais vous ce que les livres
et moi j'avais un atelier avec des
outils à la maison et donc je jonglais
les outils à l'âge de cinq ans j'avais
les outils qui m'était naturel et mes
parents qui avaient peur pour moi
pourtant laissé manier les perceuses des
jeux parce que c'était naturel pour eux
aussi il avait confié il avait confiance
pour faire une bonne éducation il faut
apprendre des choses il faut faire
comprendre faut donner confiance à
l'enfant donné confiance à l'enfance et
lui dire aux réfléchir c'est la preuve
tu apprends oui mais tu oses réfléchir
et puis une fois si tu as une idée aux
la mettre en action parce qu'il ya des
tas de gens qui ont des idées mais qui
n'ose pas
le faisait aussi par des jeux par
exemple y avait un jeu du lézard je
crois oui bah le temps devrait rappeler
mon grand père est agriculteur donc mon
père ne lisez pas mais que je sais
parfaitement la nature
donc quand ils étaient en vacances et a
aidé les arts sur les pierres et donc il
m'expliquer comment attraper un des arts
donc me prenait beaucoup de choses parce
que sam a prôné la patience il fallait
ne pas bouger devant la pierre après il
m'expliquer comment mettre la main sans
bouger après il m'expliquait que c'était
dans ce trou et pourquoi et pourquoi
c'est un et des tas de choses comme ça
jusqu'au moment où on était là la masse
sur les arts et puis de temps en temps
dans un pays où il y avait la queue qui
partait et quand vous savez que quelques
du lézard cantal et coupez-les fraitis
et quand il lâche son agresseur et le
serpent manche la queue du lézard et le
serpent ça va mais surtout moi en
médecine dans la dans le lézard et dans
la queue de l'usr et sa régénération il
y à toute la vie c'est à dire que on ne
se rend pas compte le nook ce camp
lorsque je fais une petite plaie on
s'émerveille pas de ces choses là mais
on cicatrices ion cicatrisera pas avec
une petite plaie on mourait et la queue
du lézard régénère et dans la recherche
actuelle la régénération c'est le secret
de l'éternité et le jour on sera
vraiment régénérer les choses les
cellules et le problème c'est que plus
on devient intelligent dans l'arbre a ni
animal - on s'est régénéré
vous avez des exemples
rachel kahn de l'enfance de choses qui
vous rend été transmises à travers des
jeux des anecdotes
non mais en fait juste dans l'enfance
c'est vrai que dans l'enfance on se
cicatrisent beaucoup moi je me rappelle
juste évidemment je courais petit et
d'ailleurs se bat et les garçons ah bon
on fait dieu ça
je dis trop fort et et c'est vrai qu'à
ses cicatrices je crois que la
transmission peut-être c'est ça c'était
ses cicatrices que l'on a dans nos
humanités
et cette procédure de réparation que
l'on doit transmettre puisque la
transmission c'est transmettre
transmission au delà de notre mission
est de 2 par an de notre de notre
génération à nos enfants on doit réparer
nos humanités à mon sens et voilà cette
cicatrice dans deux audis rocade c'est
que en transmettant on répare quelle
forme allemand devrait réparer c'est
normalement ce que l'on doit transmet
les en report est quoi nos humanités
pour moi ce serait se seraient nos
humanités après tous ces crimes contre
l'humanité depuis des siècles mais les
fautes des parents ne tombe pas sur les
enfants n'ont pas du tout non mais l'âge
je vais comment au-delà dans la
transmission dans dans la mission au
delà et d'ailleurs les crimes contre
l'humanité ne concerne pas que les
concernés les crimes contre l'humanité
concerne l'humanité tout entière alors
lorsque la transmission c'est un acte
amoureux alors on n'a pas encore
prononcé avec amour et je crois que le
le cadeau qu'on peut faire un enfant
c'est de lui dire je suis déconcerté et
des parents sont souvent d être
déconcerté mais je te regarde
ça va pas dire je tape rouge forcément
mais c'est à lui faire le crédit d'un
regard et ça c'est beaucoup et je pense
qu'il ya beaucoup d'êtres humains qui
n'ont pas été regardé et que la blessure
elle est pleine il a alors pas ce
déficit de regard aux cinq lambron dans
vos livres notamment dans le dernier oui
vous transmettez la beauté d'une ville
lyon
quelquefois on relate on transmet un
souvenir d'enfance un traumatisme à
votre avis qu'est-ce qui pousse chacun
d'entre nous d'entre vous à être le
passeur de soi vers les autres c'est un
commandement intérieur qui fait qu'on on
ne pense que c'est une saga avec la
trace je pense que ça a à voir avec le
signe je pense que c'est une façon de
dire je suis passé à livre quoi qu'il
vaille c'est comme quelque chose qui est
inscrit qui est marqué
presque comment une sorte de stigmates
et moi je ne sais pas évidemment quelle
fortune auront ce livre mais je me dis
que peut-être je l'aurai un jour un
petit fils soit l'arrière petit fils
puis deux filles qui dira et comme un
drôle de type qui est essayé d'écrire et
voilà ce qu'il a raconté de son temps et
ça restera comme une sorte de borne dans
la filiation et sarah comptera quelque
chose du temps qu'on a connus ou qu'ont
connu les disparus parce qu'un livre
c'est ça c'est la parole des disparus
qui éventuellement traverse le temps et
qui peut aider ce qu'on ne connaîtra
jamais savoir d'où ils viennent
alors pour vous un lien avec 1,6
transmettre c'est
vouloir montrer
ce que vous devez à votre père et que
vous lui restituer
quelques jours au delà de ça c'est
s'inscrire dans une chaîne de père en
fille
et qui vient de très très loin j'ai
remonté dans mon livre le fil de cette
chaîne qui doit s accomplir je pense que
rachel kahn a raison de dire que c'est
une réparation c'est peut-être même une
réparation du monde cette transmission
parce que finalement ce que l'on veut
transmettre ses valeurs effectivement
d'humanité qui viennent
peut-être construire une société où l'on
pourrait vivre puis on essaye et à
chaque fois on échoue au moins on essaye
quoi voici maurice mimoun vous avez
cherché à engendrer à nouveau votre père
en écrivant et moi je sais écrire c'est
un peu se quitter pour moi c'est
s'acquittait de quelque chose c'est
rendre ce qu'on m'a donné ce qu'on n'a
pas deux mais ceux-ci se réfléchir sur
soi même c'est faire le point avec soin
et c'est aussi transmettre aux gens
qu'il faut pas tellement je pense que
quand on suspend ce taureau à
transmettre on transmet plus donc on
transmet beaucoup malgré soi et si on si
on est à côté et qu'on essaye on
transmet pas quoi donc il faut il faut
pas être faussée dans la vérité qu'on
transmet l'enfant en tout cas le regard
de l'enfant le sait très bien il ya
beaucoup de livres aussi aujourd'hui
écrit souvent par des petits enfants 3e
4e génération qui redonne ou qui donnent
une parole à ceux qui ne l'ont pas eu
c'est à dire aux grands parents parce
qu'ils ont disparu parce qu'ils étaient
analphabètes parce qu'il ya toutes
sortes de raisons transmettre c'est
aussi remonter ou redonner quelque chose
à ceux qui étaient là avant
raphaël cannes en mai par rapport à ça
je trouve que c'est enfin voila si je
suis bouleversée à chaque fois lorsque
je repense à perec parce qu'en fait il a
essayé justement à ceux qui ont disparu
et puis de de
reconstituer des souvenirs en fait dans
un désespoir en tentant de de vivre et
d'avoir cette gratitude en fait par
rapport à
être en vie alors qu'il a été coupé de
cet héritage là en tout cas de se
reconstituer la presque de manière sûre
j pour vous pour vos quant à georges
perec d'y être juif c'est une question
c'est se remettre en question c'est vous
c'est ce que vous ressentez vous
personnellement en tout cas c'est non
mais être juif ou question enfin c'est
une identité en mouvement en tout cas
une identité en en questionnement
permanent mais en tout cas en essayant
de réinterpréter et donc de transmettre
derrière interprétation différente mais
là lorsqu'on a été coupée de ses parents
c'est georges perec c22 de tenter de
retrouver de s'accrocher au moindre
souvenir pour pouvoir justement c'est ce
qu'il a écrit il a écrit en fait un
souvenir qu'il n'avait pas il y avait un
assez beau livre oui dans cette rentrée
c'est le livre de la rentrée dernière
d'anne berest effectué une recette au
fond de 4,4 prénom votre carte postale
que sont ces prêts donc ce que ça
raconte et après 400 pages pour remonter
recréer un monde et goûtèrent on va
bientôt comme l'est le temps court on va
bientôt conclure si vous voulez bien
dans vos engagements à chacun chacune
d'entre vous engagement littéraire
notamment dans vos appréciations vos
passions et cetera est-ce que
vous avez le sentiment les uns les
autres que vous cherchez comme dirait
nietzsche à fertiliser le passé où elle
est également à redonner une vie aux
êtres y vous sont chers comme proust
dans ses romans
eliette abécassis entre nietzsche et
proust ou vous êtes par rapport à ça oui
je pense j'aime beaucoup m'inscrire dans
l'histoire d'un peuple
c'est
la vie d'un individu c'est du mal à
m'intéresser à juste juste moi ou mon
histoire sinon dans dans le cas d'une
épopée beaucoup plus vaste ce soit celle
des sépharades qu'il n'est pas c'est
raconter qu'ils en sont aussi en train
de s'éteindre et de mourir de trop
d'oralité même si ce magnifique ou celle
des juifs celle de ma culture française
quelque chose de plus vaste marc lambron
est ce que vous diriez comme à dare est
que quand on est attaqué
sur un plan personnel il faut répondre
par rapport à son lot lien avec le
peuple auquel on appartient ça dépend je
pense que je suis pas assez attaqué est
passé par un zodiac donc
c'est plutôt un bienheureux cet égard le
rapport que j'aurais par exemple en
tenant un journal
je pense que l'idée qui est une
projection vers le futur c'est pas de
raconter mes états d'âme qui sont 130
intérêt mais c'est plutôt l'idée qu'on a
chez victor hugo par exemple des choses
vu ta deja pour photographique avec ce
qui se passe avec l'air du temps avec
une époque essayez de l'inscrire et
éventuellement de travailler pas pour un
sociologue un historien qui plus tard
aura une une matière on n'écrit pas
forcément pour le présent d'ailleurs on
peut avoir des projection hypothétique
vers un lecteur qui n'existe pas encore
pour vous rachel kahn il faut faire
utiliser le passé pour donner un sens au
présent c'est à dire on vient de quelque
part on va quelque part
si je suis ce que je serai
évidemment que nous nous racines qu'elle
soit qu'elles soient des racines de
notre sens mais de notre racines de nos
cultures puisque on n'est pas un peuple
ethnique on n'est pas un peu plus
religieux nous sommes un peuple
politique autour de petits trésors que
sont nos principes fondamentaux
effectivement c'est ça ce socle commun
la il nous permet de devenir quelque
chose de faire quelque chose de ce récit
de ce récit à la fois sur notre
territoire mais de manière plus alors
maurice mimoun
avoir
fertiliser le passé s'est donné un peu
de sang sont présents et le projeter
vers l'avenir c'est à dire laisser
quelque chose une trace comme dit marc
lambron s'étonnant que moi j'ai horreur
de nostalgie ou ce qu'il faut regarder
en avant et nous avait posé la question
et social qu'on n'a pas résolu
aujourd'hui
pourquoi on a besoin du passé pour
regarder devant parce que l'essentiel
c'est que deux en décidant d'être bon
devant et bien on a besoin on a besoin
je le vois dans mes consultations avec
les patients les souffrances il faut
regarder derrière qu'on a eu un mauvais
père une mauvaise mère des gens ne s'en
sortent pas donc c'est et puis écrire ce
qui est un petit peu à côté mais je vais
commencer dans mon livre par la phrase
de marine at ça a été bon il ne faut
écrire que les vivres dans l'absence
fait souffrir on est rassuré d'écrire
des souvenirs parce que on n'a plus peur
de les perdre je veux une chose sur
l'étang conquérir ce qu'on a reçu
conquérir ce qu'on a reçu si vous avez
cette phrase là ça je pensais explique
beaucoup de travail d'écrivain leur
attention en somme comme vous l'avez dit
je suis ce que je serai alors ça
rappelle savez ces mots en fimo logique
donc par le freud c'est des mots qui
disent une chose et son contraire par
exemple le mot passage il ya le mot
passé et l'action de passer finalement
on est tous des passeurs ça vous semble
le passage c'est la mort ou sur français
à la fin si le fait de ne pas être sage
oui
effectivement balle aurait goûté
soyons pas avant tout je voudrais je
voudrais vous soumettre cette
bibliographie qui a servi à pour
préparer l'édition et qui est votre
oeuvre alors eliette abécassis la
transmission alors c'est un éloge du
père mais un éloge du père à la fois
intellectuel affectueux
retrouvez votre histoire et c'est tout
ce qui vous a transmis et vous le faites
aucun reproche
c'est une enquête littéraire je dirais
tu fais aucun nom mais ce n'est pas
l'objet du livre c'est plus un livre sur
la transmission à travers la figure du
père de mon père est qu'est ce qu'il en
a pensé alors je sais pas c'est très
déroutant en fait d'écrire sur
des personnes qui deviennent des
personnages forcément et et j'ai juste
parce que ça lui a plu mais pas
forcément c'est il l'a lu ah oui il l'a
lu corrigé repris
[Musique]
et il est il et il est très modeste il
aime pas du tout qu'on parle de lui donc
je crois que ça lui a pas plu finalement
sur le dis la vérité
marqué l'année du coq de feu mais
aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on appelle un
diariste et là vous avez pris l'année
2010 est alors ce qui est frappant dans
votre très beau livre c'est que vous
parlez beaucoup d autres avec un certain
détachement pour raconter la vie
parisienne alors vous avez vos têtes de
turcs que vous avez les baies personne
que vous aimez bien finalement comment
vous arrivez à faire
cette distinction entre ceux que vous
aimez ce que vous n'aimez pas ce qui
vous insupporte et c'est une question
cutanée allergies ou pas allergique et
pour ne répondre à une question que vous
me posez pas m'écouter pause et avec à 6
ma mère est encore vivante et elle a
avec ce que peut écrire une sorte de
rapport télépathique et inconditionnelle
et bien c'est très c'est très rassurant
et très porteur de savoir que vous avez
encore à mon âge probation
inconditionnel d'une mère qui est
toujours là à ce que vous écrivez à son
écoute seule écoute inconsciente vous
avez le sentiment qu'elle est derrière
elle est derrière vous quand vous tenez
la plume je pense c'est peut-être alors
l'enfant qui revient que le fait d'avoir
une mère approbatrice encore qui hélas
un toit au-dessus de la tête est quelque
chose qui vous fait vivre où il dans une
sorte de confort ou de houe de bonheur
intérieur et d'écriture et comment ce
fait vous intéressiez que des gens somme
toute assez célèbre est-ce que vous
pensez que les autres n'ont pas de place
dans un catalogue comme le vôtre bah
vous savez c'est la vie d'un village
alors tout le monde à tout le monde a le
sien il se trouve personne n'est parfait
que je suis plutôt dans quelques
arrondissements parisiens je suis
paresseux je suis un paysan de paris
mais un provincial qui est arrivé à
paris et je continue à être un peu gogo
être un peu émerveillé par le pouvoir
multiplicateur d'une ville monde une
capitale ce que ce que j'ai il montre
ses paris ou lyon parce que c'est lyon
qui d'un coeur lui ne me soigne de
l'autre c'est ça quelques santé et et
lyon me donne une sorte de troisième
oeil de regards latéral qui me permet de
ne pas être tout à fait dupe précisément
de et la comédie humaine et vous avez
cette formule en disant que vous aimez
beaucoup lyon met à l'abri de ces
bourgeois à l'abri de ces bourgeois oui
oui on dit qu'on aime souvent une ville
contre sa bourgeoisie bon voilà
celle de lyon n'a pas eu d'égalité
maurice mimoun fils 2 et alors là c'est
un livre de reconnaissance est un livre
de
vous chercher est-ce que vous avez
inconsciemment envie de réhausser ce
qu'a été le père c'est à dire montrer
que finalement il n'a pas été dans la
lumière social dans la mondanité mais
qu'il avait en lui d'
des forces considérables qui se sont
exprimés à travers vous et votre
réussite sociale je réponds simplement
oui effectivement il avait cette
modestie de départ va voir tirer la
couverture à lui c'est moi qui lui la
tire mais c'est un livre sur mon père
mais deux du particulier au général
j'espère que mon livre ses tarifs sur
les paires et comme je vous dis je parle
des paires détestable des gens qui n'ont
pas eu de père et quand même dès que
j'ai commencé à l'écrire et gelé mis
dans le livre je suis posé la question
je me suis dit mais qu'elles vont que
vont dire ces patients jallet ou ses
lecteurs qui ont des enfants ce plus
difficile et donc j'essaye de faire
comprendre de donner une recette et on
peut dire qu'il ya beaucoup de chose de
soi alors j'écris j'ai un père parfait
je le pense vraiment mais j'ai écrit
aussi
l'objectivité et une excroquerie de
l'esprit
est-ce qu'il ya aussi une visée
politique à travers sa politique au sens
aristotélicien à savoir que vous
restaurer la présence des pères dans une
société qui a décidé que les personnes à
rien non parce que je veux comme je veux
dire en début de 11e but de démission je
pense qu'il pourrait élever un enfant il
faut au moins deux personnes et que le
père ait d'un côté ou l'autre série
billy a maintenant une multitude de
possibilités pour élever bien un enfant
je viens on évoquait des mots de sartre
au début il ya des livres sur la chance
de ne pas avoir eu de père
alors je vais maintenant présenter le
livre de rachel kahn alors rasées on
connaît la race on connaît le mot
raciste on connaît racisées aujourd'hui
et bouras et or vous en faites un style
c'est quoi c'est précieux ses intimes
c'est oui c'est un peu tout à la facétie
intime oui mais vous avez dit tout à
l'heure le mot de traces mais en fait
c'est ce que j'entende principalement je
le dis pas à mes c'est ce que j'entends
dans race et c'était aussi il est de
d'une trace de quelque chose qu'on m'a
transmis évidemment sur cet héritage ce
pedigree par rapport à saumos c'est
parce que j'aime bien ce mot race et qui
est un mot un joli mot de la langue
française très peu utilisé avec
plusieurs définitions donc on peut
l'interpréter comme on veut avec un thé
ça fait tracer rachètera c'est ce que
oui c'est ça voilà et est en
réalité par rapport à ces histoires de
réseaux sociaux en fait qui
amoindrissent les identités qui nous
appauvrissent qui appauvrissent le
langage bien souvent on nous donne des
mots qui n'ont plus de définition
multiples et racé tracé c'est c'est
aussi cette intimité de mes parents et
de cette langue française puisqu'on vit
une période de dérèglements sémantique
merci de la trace que vous avez apporté
mesdames merci messieurs je voudrais
remercier l'équipe dès le cp et je vous
laisse avec cette pensée qui fêtera ça
mon avis donne toi un m même si celui ci
n'est pas apte à être ton maître fait le
de sorte que le savoir que tu acquiers
par l'étude sa firme est dur c'est de
qui alliait abécassis d'après vous
c'était nos tissus nécrosés maïmonide
levinas mais
décembre hamel merci
[Musique]